at the Feast of the Lord which you shall
Proclaim to be in season in their season
ah say that again in their season the
Sabbath has no
season the Sabbath is all the time the
Feast of Tabernacles was at a certain
time in the year the Sabbath has no
season all the other feasts they are the
season not the Sabbath and so it is set
aside in verse three by itself then from
verse four all the way down to the end
of that chapter we have the seven feasts
from Passover to the Feast of
Tabernacles each based on the day of the
month not in connection to the
week are you with me yes the Sabbath of
God is as people say well the calendar
has been changed yes but not the order
of the
days are you with me you in other words
today is the 20th okay President Biden
can say okay let's make it the 27th and
what gain some days or lose some days
whatever we'll consider today the 27th
so you jumped ahead seven days but the
order of the days remain the same Sunday
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Sabbath the calendars have been changed
yes but the order of the days have not
been changed it is still Sunday through
Saturday the seventh day is the Sabbath
let me put this to you my friends online
stay with
us how many of you were Sunday Keepers
before you joined the church can I see
your hands I was one on what day did
your Church Celebrate
Easter come on tell me loudly on Sunday
you know
why that's the day on which Christ rose
right so in that sense the churches were
right on the day he rose on the first
that's why Easter is always celebrated
on a Sunday not on a Wednesday are you
following me when is Good Friday
celebrated Good Friday because that's
when he was
crucified what's the day between
Saturday if you're honest the Sabbath is
not a problem if you're
honest if you're observing Sunday ask
God for the spiritual courage to change
amen
amen Jesus died because the law was
broken
mhm MH that's the only reason why Christ
died the law was
broken and no law breaker will enter
God's kingdom no matter how popular law
breaking is Sabbath keeping is very
unpopular yes but God has never had the
majority amen stay faithful amen and for
those of you listening ask God for the
courage to make that change please
sorry it took so
long what is the church stand on women
covering their hair during worship
service okay that's another issue which
the church has no official declaration
it does not have but I was a boy most
women cover their
heads if you read 1 Corinthians 11: 3 to
8 there's an argument for women covering
their heads and Paul argues on the basis
of creation he says in verse
but I would have you know that the head
of every man is Christ and the head of
the woman is the man and the head of
Christ is
God every man praying or prophesying
having his head covered dishonor his
head and every woman that pray prayeth
or prophesieth with her head covered
uncovered dishonor her head you've got
to figure out what head is which head
look at verse three again but I would
have you
read
microscopically the head of every man is
CH are you looking at verse three the
head of every man is Christ so we have a
head referring to a person the head of
the woman is the man the man is the head
of the home and the head of Christ is
God are you with me how many heads do we
have in verse
three name them in order of
importance God he's the head of
whom what's the next head
he's ah head of whom what's the next
head he's ah head of whom keep that in
mind now read verse
four every manay praying or prophesying
with his head covered
dishonor his head now how many heads did
you have there no no no no no look again
how many heads do you see two which one
is
biological which one is a biolog iCal
head which one means Christ the second
yes when a man worship with his head
covered you've got a beanie on your head
you're dishonoring your head not your
skull
Jesus who's your head n every woman who
prayeth that prayeth or prophesy with a
head uncovered dishonor her head how
many heads in that verse one oh which
one is biological
which one is Christ or the man yeah you
dishonor the
man now yeah you look so shocked
Paul Paul goes on to say read verse six
for me what does that
say for woman not covered for if a woman
be not covered let her be Shor but if
it's a shame for a woman to be Shor or
shaven let her be be covered now read
verse 7 for a man indeed ought not
to why for as much is the image and the
glory of God but the woman come on is
the glory of the man now pause before we
have Civil War
wait listen to me
carefully
yeah let me come close to you so you can
see I mean no harm
when God made Adam and Eve which one did
he make first Adam Adam how did he make
Eve from from a part of
Adam when God made Adam Adam received
the image of God
directly the woman received the image
how through
Adam now if you want to bring social
issues into the Bible that that's your
choice you'll confuse yourself the man
receive the image of God
directly by God's Arrangement the woman
received it through the man but same
image don't misunderstand me not a lower
quality that just a different modality
of
delivery because of that the man is the
head read verse eight what does verse
eight verse eight what does verse eight
say for a man is not of the woman is not
of the woman come on but a woman of the
man what does that mean was Adam made
from a rib from Eve no how was Eve made
a rib from Adam so the Bible say the man
did not come from the woman the woman
came from the man question for you are
you reading the Bible do you see that is
that what's recorded in Genesis all
right read the next verse
neither man neither what was a man made
for the woman but the woman was made for
the
man God said I will make him and help
meet for
him now let me say it again if you're
listening to this through sociological
lens you'll have a heart
attack we live in a society where
everyone is ahead
that's not
biblical now for those of you men who
saying ah I'm so glad for the
[Laughter]
Bible the head of the home is not the
boss in the Bible a head is a servant
are you with me so the Bible says
husbands love your wives how even as
Christ loved the church and gave a
husband's first duty to the wife wife is
to be willing to die for
her you don't beat someone you're
willing to die for the Bible says die
for her don't kill her die for her that
is self-sacrifice are you with me and
any woman will fall a man who makes it
obvious and willing to die for
you and so the wearing of hats on the
head if you study the passage carefully
Paul is not arguing culturally he goes
back to Creation
on the basis of the order of creation
the man's head should be uncovered and a
woman's head should be
covered Nobody Does it today but I gave
you a verse Psalm 50: 20 these things
how that done and I kept silence there
sometimes God says nothing not because
he agrees he just says man these people
just won't listen so he just keeps
quiet are you following me he keep keeps
quiet not because he agrees he just
keeps quiet and whatever God does is
right but biblically the Bible is
telling us clearly the lady should cover
her head and the man should not cover
his
but if it's as it is now it is almost
non-existent and God keeps quiet mhm but
don't go judging people and condemning
people now don't do that condemning
people is not a gift of the spirit are
you with me there are no policemen in
the church and don't start that movement
policing people don't do that the Bible
says work out your own salvation too
many people try to work out somebody
else's Salvation let's not do that yes
we care about each other I mean if you
find out that head Elders running Casino
where we have to talk to him are you
following me yes but generally speaking
let people work out their own salvation
because God deals with us at different
times he convicts us at different times
under different circumstances all right
do you have an easy question yeah okay
okay since you mentioned about the man
being the head I will jump to this
question that says Ephesians 5:22 says
wives submit yourselves unto your own
husbands as unto the Lord uhhuh from a
Biblical standpoint what does that what
does it mean for a woman to submit to
her husband please provide practical
examples well it's simple to submit to
your husband is to acknowledge the
headship that God has given to him you
acknowledge him as a head of the home
you respect him as a head of the home
God has aign he did not set it up God
arranged it Christ and the church is the
high model for the husband and the wife
Christ is the head of the church the
husband's ah head of the house so
submission simply means this is the head
of my home the head of the children the
head of the SK family the head of the
whomever a family simple as that it does
not mean you must violate your
conscience the fact that husband is the
head he cannot ask you to do something
that violates your conscience he just
can't do it or ask you to break God's
law cannot do it because you have a
higher head who is that God yes you have
a higher head but when things are run
God's way that's when life is most fully
blessed God's not society's
way the church must not be influenced by
societal movements it must be led by
thus sayth the Lord
and because we're so blessed to have
God's servant the writings of Ellen
White but if you read what the Bible
says about an ideal wife in Proverbs 31:
10-31 a man who has a wife like that is
blessed beyond measure she's intelligent
she's a business woman she knows how to
take care of her family she knows how to
run a business she has a wholesome
reputation the husband is proud of her
all of you read proverbs 31 10-31 you
see that woman oh that's a
woman but God's order is the head of the
home the man that's not what's the word
um
chauvinism that's a Biblical
teaching God is the head of Christ and
there's no problem Gabriel is the head
of all the Angels there's no problem the
high priest was the head of all the
Levites no problem David was the
physical head of the nation no problem
God arranged there must be ahead ahead
ahead your oldest child is above the
little
children you don't put your 5-year-old
in charge of your 12-year-old boy
mm next
question Psalm 150: 3-6 enjoins us to
praise the Lord with the sound of
trumpets loud symbols drums Etc MH and
uh and even dance but I Church frowns at
these mhm is the is the use of
controlled and resp is the controlled
and responsible use of musical
instruments like drums and trumpets
during our worship Services wrong since
the Bible encourages their use to praise
God additionally is there a reason we
should not we should not sing
inspirational songs except it is a hymn
we should not sing inspirational songs
all right I don't know I'm not sure what
an inspirational song is
now I was talking to some very lovely
young people there is no sin in an
instrument that's a
piano that's an
organ but be honest with me which one
sounds more
churchy Oran M mhm you hear organ church
that's no condemnation to piano but you
hear an organ you're a church now if you
go to rock concert do you see a piano
what do you see your guitar what else do
you see ahuh drums Guitar absolutely
indispensible
now can you run the church service
without drums yes yes will introducing
them cause a problem for some yes yes
now El white writes I don't recall where
I can get it for you just before the
close of probation there will be a style
of worship that is based on loud
noise in the Adventist churches and she
mentions drums
particularly noise loud noise deadening
the senses making people unable to make
Intelligent Decisions she said just
before the close of probation this will
come into the church loud noisy worship
and the central instrument is the
drum there's no sin in the drum as I was
telling my young friends there's
something called The Law of asso
assciation are you with me law of
Association now if a guy commits a crime
he he holds up a liquor store and you
standing right next to him and the
police come in they stop him and
you they will arrest him and you because
you're right there are you with me later
on they'll sort it out are you following
me by
association have you ever heard of the
magazine Playboy yes don't buy don't
look at it but you've heard of it what's
the logo of a
Playboy the head of a rabbit yes that's
why the girls are called bunnies the
head of a rabbit is the logo for this
pornographic magazine but who made
rabbits God on the sixth
day I would not take the head of a
rabbit and put it on a t-shirt are you
following me because people seeing that
will not think of
creation they think of Playboy
that guy's a preacher why is he
advertising Playboy no I'm advertising
creation but who would believe that now
that's the law of
Association now the rabbit has been
associated with Playboy so I distance
myself from the
rabbit are you with me you take
dreadlocks blessings upon you you go
back to Jamaica God bless Jamaica
there's a religion called
rastafarianism dreadlocks they smoke
stuff part of their worship is to regard
a man as a god who's that man high
salassi
yes they see Visions when they have this
this smoke that stuff contrary to what
the Bible teaches so when you run around
with your dreadlocks you may not be R
forai are you following me but what
comes to people's minds you you see the
problem is when someone sees you where
do you want the person's mind to
go because the Bible says god holds us
responsible for the influence we exert
on
others so if I come to church looking
like I know a rapper and some little boy
starts dressing that way God blames
me and so some things in and of
themselves may be innocent but because
of the association that has developed
between them and something else it's
best to leave it alone
no one will go to hell because he
doesn't play a drum no one will go to
hell for playing a
drum but again I say what image do you
project so we must be wise as serpents
harmless as doves and avoid worship
styles that resemble the other
churches when God gave the great gospel
commission Matthew 2818 to20 and Jesus
came and spake unto them saying all
power is given unto me in heaven and in
Earth what does verse 19 say go ye
therefore and do what teach it did not
say go ye therefore and
learn with respect to the gospel you can
learn physics and chemistry not the
gospel go ye therefore and teach teach
them what I've taught you don't let them
teach
you you go teach them how to sing how to
worship how to give how to study the
Bible how to run their homes how to
improve their health how to deal with
the state you teach them all things that
I have commanded you teach
them don't let them teach
you and there's too much of Sunday
churches coming into our
church have you seen some videos online
about some camp meeting
are you you seen them okay next
question says here Pastor I notice you
you just like some other you're just
like some other Adventist quote from the
writings of Ellen White a lot what do
you say to those who accuse Adventist of
upholding Ellen White above the Bible is
that another that's another part of it
the Seventh Day Adventist Church does
not Elevate elen White's writings above
the Bible absolutely not I mean she
herself says the Bible and the Bible
alone do not put her writings on the
level of the Bible they're not now she
was inspired as Isaiah are you with me
but there are books in the Bible that
are not part of the Bible they are
mentioned in the Bible that are not in
the cannon of the Bible you understand
you read Chronicles and Kings the book
of jasher The Book of dispers and the
Book of the Kings we don't know what
those books are but they were used back
then but they're no longer part of the
cannon Ellen White's writings are a
commentary on the Bible but an inspired
commentary given to this church not the
world to this church to bless and she
has kept this church from one
catastrophe after the other doctrinally
mm we do not Elevate her above but when
I preached on Adventist Church because
reading her writings is falling out of
style I deliberately quot from her to
try to stimulate someone to go take a
Peak at steps to Christ or Desire of
Ages or Patriarchs and Prophets amen you
become blessed M so the church does not
view Ellen White's writings on the same
level of the Bible not absolutely not
yes it's beneath way beneath you can't
have a competitor for thus sayith the
Lord what's the second part of the
question says why do Adventists hold her
writing so highly even when she made
some predictions that were are not
fulfilled that's not true there's no
legitimate prediction El white ever made
that did not come through through like
the Bible elte must be studied here a
little there a little for instance elte
wrote uh don't buy
bicycles that's when bicycles were first
invented and they were a craze and they
were expensive they were church members
using God's money just to be part of a
fashion because fashion has tremendous
power over people if Jane has it I have
to have it if Jack has it I have to have
it and so she counseled people don't
spend God's money on bicycles but what
bicycles are today day she would never
say that mm- so you've got to judge her
writings based on when and to whom she
was writing and you apply principles to
her to her writings elen says uh we
should not eat certain things like avoid
eggs and whatever else but she also says
eggs have healing qualities but the time
will come when we want eat them safely
because of disease but who determines
for you when that time has come are you
following me it can't be
me but she does say eggs have healing
qualities so if someone buys free rench
eggs for some vegetarian who protects
the chickens I'm not passing judgment
are you following me and
so Ellen
White all her
predictions have come
through that's why the church accepts
her gift as genuine Ela white was given
Visions in which she saw things that
happened years before they actually
happened mhm before she went to Europe
she was given a vision of some people in
Europe in a meeting a couple years later
she went to Europe and she saw the
people and told them what she saw and
they were
astonished there was a meeting she saw
six weeks before it happened the Lord
showed it to
her and uh six weeks later just before
the meeting took place or was about to
take place she was in a public meeting
and she could not remember what the Lord
show her but she knew it was connected
with what was going on right then but
she could not remember so she went back
to her room then it came to her then she
went back to the meeting and told them
what she saw and this man stood up and
confessed that what she saw is exactly
what happened and he repented it was
General repentance people were making
decisions contrary to God's will that
woman had the gift of
Prophecy and do yourself of
favor and Sample her writings amen mhm
let your children read messages to young
people are you in a courtship read
messages to young people read letters to
young lovers are you a young couple just
got married considering children read
the Adventist home read
education you want to know how all this
started sin go read Patriarchs and
Prophets and the story of redemption
you're concerned with your health read
counsels and diet and Foods read the
ministry of
healing how do I manage my money read
councils on
stewardship we got all these secular
sources for information and we have a
wealth of information from Divine source
and we there's a story I was told two
men went to a Sunday
preacher who had a large congregation
two Adventist preachers went to him how
did you get such a large church we want
to build our church so he reached back
to his library and handed them
evangelism by Ellen
White now those two ministers should
have been fired on the spot he handed
them
evangelism by Ellen
White and they're coming to him what to
do next question the last part of that
question says how do we know that some
of our writings on fast that we are not
explicitly in the Bible are true say
that again how do we know that some of
high writings on facts that we are not
explicitly in the Bible are true some of
her writings on what on the fact that
are not in the Bible are true pretty
much like some of our writings that are
not in the Bible uhhuh so they asking if
those how do we know that those writings
are true well oh yeah there there's even
scientific proof that El White's
writings are true there are some
scientific statements El and you may get
from General Conference if you call them
a paper that issued several years ago
which showed modern scientific
discoveries on what Ellen White said 100
years before they were discovered you
can get that paper for instance El said
that electricity controls the heart I'm
paraphrasing her words the heart runs by
electrical currents she said that long
before scientists knew that electrical
currents are operated the heart she said
that El white said she made many
scientific statements she was not a
scientist but she had Revelations from
God and you can get that paper as I said
earlier from the GC if they still have
it that shows scientific developments
and what she said hundreds of years
before those discoveries were
made there was a fellow called Joseph
bate one of the founders of the church
he was a sea captain so he had to
navigate by the Stars he had to know
them very well El white was about 17 18
she'd gotten a vision and she was
relating the vision and he was sitting
there and as he listened he said this
girl got this from God that's the only
way she could know all that stuff she
just said and he knew it was right
because it was his business as a
professional Captain to know how the the
heavenly bodies moved and navigate by
the stars and that's when he made his
decision to join this uh this gift is
real doctors have examined her when she
was Invision she never breathed when she
was invisioned
and doctors came and examined her and
she stood there not breathing not even
blinking staring off she was extra
strong and they could not detect a
breath and she would Envision two hours
3 hours could not detect a breath
because the Bible says prophets there
was no breath in them when God came to
them because God sustained them during
that visitation and after the vision
ended she would take a deep breath and
start breathing on her own on one
occasion she held out a Bible which was
several pounds heavy if you think you
stretch your hand out like this now
according to the law of physics this is
a lever and the longer this lever is the
more difficult it is to hold a weight if
you take a 5B weight you can hold it
here it's a short lever you put it over
here after a few minutes your hand drops
because it's so heavy you take a hammer
and you hold it by the very end and the
head drops you just can't keep up the
head you hold it close to the head
there's no problem she held it out for a
long time and those present said this is
superhuman power that's the only way she
could have held that Bible for so long
and able-bodied Men could not do
it thing she said would happened that
happened warning she gave to people that
actually happened as she
said there
are there's go to go to the El white
website the El white estate there's
Source places you can go to learn the EG
white State books written defending her
gift you can go to there's an office in
general conference called the biblical
Research Institute that office's only
work is to do research and provide Bible
answers for the church leaders for them
to make Intelligent Decisions the
biblical Research Institute just put it
in go online it comes up with all kinds
of articles that teach you
but go to the Ellen White estate there's
a lot of free material and learn about
this tremendous Prophet that God has
given to his end time
Church in recent months the 7even Day
Adventist Church has been accused of
being a cult MH how are we supposed to
respond to such accusations as Believers
and how are we to defend our faith it
depends on how you define a cult Ault
is a group built around one Central
charismatic figure who exercises almost
unlimited control over all the members
there's no such person in the Adventist
Church not Ellen White not James White
not Joseph bites not Jay Andrews not UAH
not any of these persons we have one
leader and that's Jesus Christ and
Christ is not a head of a cult he's a
head of a church a
cult does not accept the Divinity of
Jesus Christ you understand the
Adventist Church is not a cult in the
1950s there was a Evangelical scholar
called Walter Martin he was writing a
book on
Cults so he interviewed Adventist
leaders and after he finished his
conclusion was it is not a
cult we are not a cult we are a church
led by Christ amen but Christ has SP
certain servants to assist in the
development and the growth of his church
Joshua was not a cult most Moses was not
a cult leader Moses was a servant of God
to guide God's people are you following
me Ellen White was a servant James White
J Andrews you named them your Smith
Joseph F J and lbo all Servants of God
to lead this church
amen how do we encourage the young the
Youth and Young adults involvement in
church get them involved in the Bible
they can be involved in church but not
with Christ
there's a movement I say that to say
this there is a belief in our church if
you make the service noisy you attract
young people you may attract them to
noise not to Christ are there's a
difference if you dress down and wear
t-shirts and jeans and and flipflops and
they'll come they're not coming to
Christ they're coming to an environment
where they can just let go the thing
that draws people to Christ is thus
sayith the Lord amen get your children
to spend a little time with the Bible
the Bible will change them
amen and change them ELO tells us
Timothy was a teenager when Paul called
him to lead
churches when God called him to lead
churches and Paul called him as an
assistant he was a
teenager but the Bible says of Timothy
from the Earth from a child thou Hast
known the holy scriptures which are able
to make thee wise through faith under
salvation he was taught by his mother
and his grandmother Unice and
lawers and he grew up under the word and
as a young boy he was a leader of the
church not running around on skateboards
a leader of the church so get your
children into the word don't send them
to the word go with them don't send them
to church take
them the word of God is what changes
people mhm
okay is it right for SDA women to wear
artificial hair is it right for a women
women who wear artificial hair to
condemn those who
don't you're asking the wrong man I have
no hair
but I am artificial hair how do you know
it's
artificial you can't walk around the
church checking people's heads it's how
do you know it's
artificial there are some things we have
to leave to people you see it's um let's
say there's a woman you know men go bald
all the time and men can handle that not
that they like it but they handle it but
for a woman to handle going bald Ah
that's traumatic now if she wears a wig
who are you to tell her she shouldn't do
that are you following me how do you
know the the psychological impact on a
woman losing her hair the Bible says her
hair is her glory so if she covers it up
I don't see and I don't have a Bible
verse but how God condemns his daughter
for
that let me if you have a uh cavity
don't you get it fixed with something
artificial it's not your real teeth it's
artificial but it's in your mouth are
you following me no one can see it a lot
of artificial things are used don't
people get hip replacements isn't it
artificial why don't you take it out
yeah it's artificial so let's not go too
far in telling people take that thing
off your head
and let's not condemn people please
please okay is the Bible against female
pastors and preachers and does what the
judge stand on women ordination the
church's position is
no no it has voted one twice three times
no ordination of women to the position
of Pastor recently somehow it was
slipped in that women could be ordained
as Elders how that happened is another
story but the church has voted
consistently no women as ordained
Pastors in the church has studied it and
has not yet seen biblical justification
for doing that I say again they have not
yet seen all they've seen based on what
they've studied that it not ought not to
happen no matter what society
says where is the storehouse of God
today the church bringing all the tithe
into the storehouse is the church that's
the Adventist position okay if you are
satisfied if you are dissatisfied with
the way things are done at the general
conference is it okay for a for a church
to keep its TI and use it to pay someone
that is preaching God's word instead of
sending it to the union or conference no
no no no no no no no k n o no Cano no
don't don't don't do that are you with
me do not do that if you do that the
condition that will de develop is the
one described in judges over and over
every man did that which is right come
on in his own eyes we have to avoid
that Jesus knew his church was corrupt
when he came to this earth did he attend
that church yes he sat in the temple and
watched a widow bringing her little
offerings to that corrupt church and he
commended her are you following me Jesus
said in Matthew 23 the Pharisees sit in
Moses's seat all things therefore they
command you do whatever they say you do
don't do what they do but do what they
tell you because they occupy Moses's
seat meaning a position of authority the
church may have corrupt leaders yes but
remember Daniel 2:21 he removeth Kings
and Seth up Kings God allows some people
in position for reasons best known to
him when he's ready he will remove them
when you return that tie you're not
returning it to the conference president
you are obeying God God will bless you
and take care of corruption do not take
this unilateral position but if you
decide to do it don't tell anyone then
you spread a negative influence you see
the local church has to be supported by
the offering the conference and upwards
by the tithe you can't disrupt it by
saying well the general conference is
corrupt so I make a decision based on my
Superior righteousness to do this or
that don't do that don't do that follow
the proceed of the church leave God to
correct What In Your Eyes is
wrong next question could you please
explain Deuteronomy 24:1 to4 which says
say read
that you me 24 1
to4 put that up for
usy okay when a man has taken a wife and
married her and it come to pass that she
find no favor in his eyes because he has
found some uncleanliness in her then let
him write her a bill of divorcement and
give it give it in her hand and send her
out of his house okay and when she she
is departed out out of his house she may
go and be another man's wife and if the
letter husband hate her and write her a
bill of divorcement and giveth it in her
hand and sendeth her out of his house or
if the let her husband die which took
her to be his wife her former husband
which sent her away may not take her
again to be his wife after that she is
defiled for for that is abomination
before the the Lord and thou sht not
cause the land to sin which the Lord thy
God giveth thee for an inheritance all
right I have no answer for that I've
never studied that I have no answer for
that
none next one
okay
um okay it says here mhm please canly
State your Bible based opinions on this
issue okay a Seventh Day Adventist
daughter decides to marry a
non-adventist gentleman seen as upright
except he does not believe in converting
to adventism that's the first question
mhm so the next one is parents let's
deal with that okay there's a daughter
mhm married you said yes a daughter an
Adventist daughter decides to marry oh
she intends to marry a non Adventist
gentlemen he's a nice man but he's not
an
Adventist
okay okay okay let me finish read
parents tried to convince their daughter
not to get into the marriage but she
refused can the parents still walk their
daughter down the aisle so Hand this
daughter over the non Adventist
gentleman as her husband no no M can't
do that the parents are aiding and
abetting in a spiritual crime you can't
do that now I know parental heartstrings
are powerful things MH I know that but
you cannot assist someone in doing which
is clearly opposing in opposition to
God's clearly stated word be not une
equally yolked together with unbelievers
can't do
that and they ought to know long before
the plans are made because surely she
must have been seeing this guy for a
while so she should have been informed
by the parents we cannot support this in
any way form of f we cannot support this
we love you we're your parents we cannot
support open Rebellion to God's word
can't do it okay mm cannot do it so so
what if the groom says he is researching
the SDA teaching but wants to word
before being truly converted uhhuh
should the parents support the marriage
no let him be
baptized even if he's baptized she will
never know if he got she got baptized
for her or for Jesus Christ she will
never
know avoid you see starting the
relationship in the first place is
wrong even before it gets to
consideration of marriage getting into
it is wrong and I hate to be so blunt
but I have no choice do not even start
it okay the last part of the question
says what should the parents do if their
daughter tells them she will marry this
gentleman whether they like it or not
there's nothing they can do you can't
arrest her there how old is she six
there's nothing they can do except cry
and pray and pray and pray and endure
The Shame by when the other neighbors
see them other Adventist there's nothing
they can do see when you raise a child
to reach a certain age your Authority is
gone largely gone I should say any
Authority you have left is based on
respect that's a woman she's decided to
violate God's word nothing you can do
mhm nothing or a young man nothing you
can
do even though you see them heading
towards heartache down the road nothing
you can
do but you cannot support it okay how
much your heart tugs for your son or
your daughter you cannot take a stand
against
God he that love a father and mother
more than me or brother or sister more
than me is not worthy of me H following
Christ can be tough yes tough decisions
MH but leaving heaven to come and die
was tough yes El tells us Jesus had to
ask the father three times before the
father said fine because it was hard for
the father to let him go even though
both had arranged it and discussed it
when the time came for him to come to
this earth he had to ask three times he
went the first time the father said no
second time no couldn't let us go but
the third time love pushed the father
yes love for us
okay it was hard for the father to let
him go so parental
whatever uh tough but Jesus said I do
always those things that please
him next question it is true that God
created Adam and gave him Eve as a
helpmate mhm what does the Bible and the
Bible alone say about gay lesbian gay
and lesbian life which the government
promotes and supports the Bible is
against same seex inter uh sexual
interactions and marital decision it is
clearly against it God put a man and a
woman you read Romans 1:
21-28 God condemns women on women men on
men if you read um the book of Jude
verse seven even as Sodom and Gomorrah
and the cities about them in like manner
giving themselves over to fornication
and going after strange flesh a man on a
man is strange flesh a woman on a woman
is strange flesh God wiped them out with
fire and he's going to wipe out this
Earth he will wipe out this Earth do you
hear me mhm it'll be
terrible somebody said years ago if God
doesn't destroy this world he has to
apologize to Sodom and gomorra
next
question what about fraternity and
sorority in universities and colleges
no what's the purpose of those
fraternities that practice hazing and
those surround you know people die from
hazing they beat you they kick you they
all kind they force you to drink out all
kinds of rubbish goes on in those
fraternity you want to fraternity join
the
Pathfinders I'm not joking join the
church this church sororities and
fraternities oh they engage in behaviors
that make the Angels
blush
mhm no
sir what about body piercing no jewelry
and Tattoos no no no no no go to uh
Leviticus
19 put verse 28 on the board under
whatever that thing
is Leviticus 19 let's read verse
28 Thou shalt
not okay read nice and clear Thou shalt
not
what make any
cuting in your
flesh now wait a minute is a piercing a
cutting
yes but the fundamental question is how
is this for the glory of
God that's the first question you ask
before making any decision to marry buy
a house go to college whatever how will
this glorify God God made me with a hole
right here why am I putting one
here
why how is this connected to God and
there's no answer for that why am I
putting a hole over
here I've seen people with with pieces
of thing in their tongue yeah
right over here
why I was in South Africa a few years
ago in a restaurant a young man and I
were having lunch the waitress came to
us for our order and she had a piece of
metal stuck right in
here nice looking young lady I said may
ask you a question yes why did you do
that she said because I wanted to that's
why we do what we do because I want to
nothing to do with God no piercings no
cuttings finish that
verse th shalt not do
what print
any now wait a minute wait a minute now
let me step back before you attack me
Thou shalt not print any
marks what does that
mean a
tattoo should I say this because I make
get some people in trouble okay let me
not look at your toes I'll look up
here is your toenail a part of you yes
or no why do you
hesitate is your toenail a part of your
body yes why do you paint it yes come on
now
[Applause]
yes is that a
mark why do you paint it now I'm looking
up so I'm not condemning you I'm looking
up my Redemption draw Nigh I'm looking
up why do you paint your
toes
why are your
fingers did you see how this will
glorify
God God is good and all the time do you
still like me a little bit okay I was
beginning to panic okay next question
okay okay what about um divorce and
remarin okay now that's
touchy but we have an answer for
that go to Matthew
19 let's read from verse
three Matthew 19 reading from verse
three is now 20 minutes to
5 when is the sun set 8:00 okay doesn't
mean we're going to eight but I'm just
checking to see when the sun sets
Matthew 19 let's pray again father as we
continue enlighten me as I try to
Enlighten your people in Jesus name I
pray
amen the Pharisees also came unto him
verse three tempting him and saying unto
him what is it lawful for a man to put
away his wife for every cause keep
reading and he answered and said unto
them what have you not read that he
which made them at the beginning
made them male and female and said what
for this call shall a man leave father
and mother and shall
be and they shall their twin shall
be wherefore there no more twin but one
flesh what therefore God hath put
together let not man put a son what is
God in favor
of no no wait a minute what is God in
favor of based on what you read stay Mar
State yes stay together married stay
together now read the next verse they
say unto him why then did Moses give a
writing of divorcement to put her away
he said un them Moses because of the
hardness of your heart suffered you to
put away your wives finish the verse but
from the beginning the original the
ideal it was not so now what do I want
to say God prefers Stay Together
sometimes that's not practical or wise
because of the severity of the situation
so the Bible allows divorce in case of
uh sexual immorality or some violation
of the marriage vow it's broken the
innocent person can
remarry the guilty person cannot well
should not because they do but should
not are you with me the guilty person
must remain single if he or she is still
a member of the church the innocent
party is free to
Remar you cannot divorce your wife
because you haven't heard from her in 6
months can't do that or you husband went
away to work in an oil field in Saudi
Arabia you haven't heard from him in 5
years no you can't divorce him there's
one clear biblical reason for divorce
and otherise supports it that is
adultery sexual immorality
ity not the fact that the man has lost
his six-pack you cannot divorce him for
that are you with me you cannot divorce
a woman because she burns the food you
cannot do that sexual immorality
violation of The Vow that's the reason
clear and plain and straight that's why
listen to me carefully those of you who
single marriage is Serious
Business there is too much romance
around marriage
eyes are
dazzled and people put more time into
court more time into weddings than into
marriages are you following me you sure
you got what I said this spend so much
for a wedding that lasts two hours and
no time under
marriage marriage is serious
business you get the right person you're
blessed and even then you have stresses
are you following me yes you do but God
helps you through there isn't a couple
that will tell you we've never had a
disagreement that does not exist but you
don't divorce because you had a
disagreement and so divorce is not
preferred by God but it is
allowed under severe
circumstances next question yes um
Pastor what about in the case of abuse
um or um somebody's been physical abuse
physical abuse
separate you can
separate but that's not
divorce you can
separate say that again well I don't
know how long I don't know how long I
don't know how
long I do not know how
long it's certainly not 2,300 days but I
don't know how long but you can separate
for a while you see listen to me
carefully you must consider some things
in a sinful world nothing is
perfect let me say let's say there's a
woman who cannot get pregnant huh
whether if she get a surrogate the
church is against
that let's say her husband is infertile
or whatever men are you can't get sperm
from a third
donor that's adultery without a man
present the church is against that or
you can have a woman donate an egg to
another woman the church tells us avoid
that it could be God is saying it is my
will for you that you not have children
that's what he told Jeremiah Jeremiah 16
do not marry do not have
children it could be God's desire do not
have children if you do you may die in
childbirth so I'm trying to save your
life don't do
it and so in an imperfect world my
brothers and sisters sometimes we have
to live with an imperfect
situation but divorce is based on
adultery if the man abuses a woman or a
woman beats up the man the abused person
can leave separate for a while see what
happens but it is not constitute grounds
for divorce according to the
Bible think and pray before you marry do
not marry because it is culturally
required because when you're in trouble
you don't find
people the same ones who kept telling
you why don't you marry why don't you
marry why don't you marry when you marry
and it goes south you can't find them
are you with me the same ones who say
why don't you have a child why don't you
have a child when you have the child you
need di up of money you can't find
them talk to
God seek wisdom if you have Godly
Parents talk to
them talk to your pastor get counsel
never think you're so wise you can just
get into that without counsel from
somebody do not do
that there too many people have written
me and said this is not the man I used
to
know I am married to another man from
the one I courted this is not the man
yes he's the man you just close your
eyes to the
signs that's all you were hoping he'd
get better marriage does not change
people it brings out of them what you
never saw because it can be so stressful
it brings out behaviors you never
saw get God into this thing
it doesn't remove stresses it
strengthens you and makes you go through
to the glory of God and you stay
together next question is invitro
fertilization IVF genetic engineering
modifications therapy and other
scientific advancements or technologies
that help life life wrong should these
be considered helpful and for good use
like properly used medication
drugs what you mentioned there's a paper
the the 7 Adventist Church published in
I think it's
1994 you can go to The Archives of the
church there's a paper on that these
scientific means of aiding uh human
reproduction I think it's called um
assisted human reproduction so you type
in s0 adst assisted human reproduction
and you read that paper the church calls
upon members to think very very
carefully think on moral lines
stewardship lines psychological lines
what's the effect on the mind consider
all these things before making a
decision for invitro fertilization or
artificial insemination or whatever else
is available based on scientific
technology the church does not tell you
what to do it counsels you think think
think and also includes what I said
earlier the fact that it may be God's
will that you not have a child but
that's so you think of all of that
think of the
cost they're very expensive very
expensive and so you talk to your God
you said father God knows he put in you
the desire to be a parent he put that in
you this desire to have a child he he
knows
that so you ask him you ask yourself
well will this child be for God's glory
or for my joy what's the number one
motivation and again I said these things
are tough decisions to make
But ultimately you have to make that
decision the church does not it simply
provides guy it does not condemn these
Technologies but it counsels us to avoid
third parties like surrogate uh a woman
being pregnant for somebody else or a
man donating sperm or woman donating an
egg the church counselors avoid those
but in vitro artificial semination
whatever else the church says consider
it very very carefully but get that
paper
and read
it type in 70 Adventist assisted human
development or human reproduction the
paper will come
up several advented Scholars met in
California they studied it then wrote
the paper I think it was in April of
1994 then in July of that same year the
church the Adcom committee voted it as
the official position of the church the
church has written positions on abortion
samesex marriage all kinds of things
it's just a matter of going going to the
website and reading for
yourself
mhm how can an individual discover and
use their gift of healing working
miracles Etc as mentioned in 1
Corinthians chapter 12 you may not have
that gift you just may not have it if
you prayed for people and nothing
happened and you nothing happened
nothing happened well perhaps that's not
your gift if you have the gift of
healing it will become obvious When you
pray for those who are sick but it could
be you do not have that gift you see you
don't choose the gift GI the spirit
gives it to you so if you want the gifts
of healing that's not the way it works
the spirit gives you a gift and it
becomes obvious to you I have this gift
so you cannot go in search of the gift
of healing now you can be a medical
missionary and counsel people and have a
tremendous effect yes but a gift of
praying for a sick person and something
happens that's a gift the spirit gives
to people whom he chooses so you can't
work on developing that gift nor can you
work on developing the gift of
tongues they're specifically given to
people the the working of Miracles is a
gift you can't learn to do that it's
given by the
spirit okay sister White made mention of
regular and irregular lines in the book
spalin and Megan collection could you
please explain what is regular and
irregular lines a regular line is a is a
organizational line are you with me so
the church administers it the church
runs it it's under direct Church
Authority and a regular line would be a
Ministry not under the direct control of
the church but fully 100% seven of the
Adventist Ministry are you following me
are you following me you sure so we call
that independent Ministry or we call it
self-supporting Ministry it's irregular
not because it's wrong is just is
outside the formal control and structure
of the church and some Ministries ought
to be away from the control of the
church irregular irregular but irregular
in that sense does not mean
rebellious because independent
Ministries work very closely with the
church because if you mess up the church
gets a bad name so even though you are
an independent Ministry you can't run
off and do whatever you like and have
the name seventhday Adventist you can't
do that that's a legal
possession and they can prevent you from
using it so an independent Ministry is
run by someone but it acknowledges the
church and the authority of the church
and its Ministry is designed to enhance
the work and the mission of the church
but irregular in that sense does not
mean
rebellious all right can you please
explain the in the investigative
judgment and how probation closes for
different people at different times oo
that's the size of Mount Kilimanjaro big
question the investigative judgment
simply
put is a reference to one of the feasts
that was held by the Israelites it was
one of the Fall feasts which was
celebrated on the 10th day of the
seventh month it was called the day of
Aton on that day it was really a day of
judgment where people had to examine
their lives the priest made an offering
for himself for the people then as ail
was uh the sins were put on him he was
taken off by a fit man Into the
Wilderness and the camp was cleansed
from all sin forever symbolically and
then a new religious year began the veil
in the temple was changed because blood
had been put on it for a year it was
changed a brand new one was put up and
the New Year began now anti typically
that began October
22844 based on the Prophecies of Daniel
from October
22844 Christ moved from the holy place
to the most holy to begin another phase
in his Priestly Ministry
that's a phase of
judgment where he is examining the lives
he's beginning with those who have
professed a relationship with him going
all the way back to Abel are you
following me the first person to die for
Christ and when this is finished with
the living with the dead then Christ
moves to the living first uh uh Peter
4:17 for the time is come that judgment
must begin at the house of God and so
Christ begins with the church in Ezekiel
9 God told the destroying Angel start at
my altar on my temple and start your
work of Destruction and so it begins
with the church and then moves out from
the dead to the living when that work is
done there will be a Global Closing of
probation are you following me Christ
takes off his miter which is what the
priest wears he puts on a kingly crown
changes his robes puts on kingly
garments leaves the most holy place and
starts to come for us when the when he
says El says an angel goes up to heaven
and tells Christ the work on Earth is
done in the ceiling is done people have
made up their minds to obey God or obey
the devil and their decisions are fixed
when that is announced Christ ends his
work and begins his return to this earth
now I told you before probation can
close for you individually before it
closes generally are you with me Ela
white writes in um Patriarchs and
Prophets 140 paragraph 1 every day the
probation of su is closing every hour Su
are passing beyond the reach of
Mercy Solomon not Solomon Saul's
probation closed while he was still
King God said because you rejected me
I've rejected you 1st Samuel 16:14 the
spirit of the Lord left him
when the spirit goes he's gone because
God gives us enough time to do what's
right so there I don't mean to frighten
you but um there are people in churches
they attend every Sabbath every Sunday
probation
closed but they're driven by the force
of habit but if you are still concerned
about your spiritual life if you still
feel convictions you know the spirit is
still wrestling with you so there are
closing of probations individually but
then there will be a global closing of
probation when the work of Christ is
finished completely and he comes back to
this earth now this is going on right
now as we speak the judgment is going
on MH right
now we don't know if Christ has passed
from the dead to the living we don't
know all we know is today you can make a
decision to be right with God we do not
know
next question but that's a big question
takes a lot of hours to really get into
that that's it Pastor for now oh that's
it that's good news
okay how are
you let me offer some humble
advice study the
Bible
please understand why you're seventh the
Adventist you're not simply a church
that goes to church on Saturday rather
than than Sunday for many of us that's
the only difference no no no no no this
church was raised up to preach a message
no other Church preaches what's that
message the three the three Angel
message God raised it up
specifically to make that the central
theme of its
preaching all of that would include
victory over sin the intercession of
Christ the Divinity of Christ Christ the
humanity of Christ the Divinity of the
Holy Spirit the the perpetuity of God's
law it has never been cancelled the
central role of the Sabbath all of that
should characterize the preaching of
God's
people Satan's original charge against
God according to Revelations from Ellen
White is that God's law cannot be
kept it's impossible to keep this law
that was his ch
he came down got Adam and Eve to fall to
prove among other things see I told you
your law cannot be kept
look Jesus came after thousands of years
to sure the
law can be
kept are you following me now Jesus
demonstrated in his life the law can be
kept perfectly but in the Jewish system
for something to be accepted as reliable
there must be at least two
witnesses in the mouth of two or three
every word shall be established so Jesus
can say I kept the law perfectly what do
you think Satan will
say I
need another
witness because your system requires two
if you Jesus say the Lord can be care
perfectly you did it in your life is
there another
witness that other Witness
has to be the
church through the power of Christ we
must demonstrate before God comes we can
live in harmony with Christ's law
through the power of Christ I said when
that occurs Christ comes so our mission
is to show the world God's law can be
kept
perfectly thus showing Satan to be what
a liar and God to be
true when we live in constant violation
of the law whose side are we supporting
Satan so Satan looks at God and says you
see Randy SK see I told you your law
can't be kept look at his brother the
law can't be kept look at her the law
can't be kept look at him this is fifth
wife the law can't be
kept now there are few who are faithful
and God says huh you see her my law can
be kept my law can be kept my law can be
kept you pick the the site you want to
be
on it's not just your life it is the
effect on God if we're faithful or
Unfaithful but we as human beings we
think of
us but God is thinking universally you
see Angels don't understand
everything they don't because they're
created that's why when God told Moses
make the ark The Mercy Seat was made of
one piece of gold the angels are made
from the same peace they're facing each
other but looking down what are they
looking at how Justice and mercy work
together that's the gospel there's the
law in the ark The Mercy Seat above how
can a just God forgive
Sinners they don't fully understand and
so in Ephesians chapter
3:9 and to make all men see what is the
Fellowship of the mystery which from the
beginning of the world had been hidden
God who created All Things by Jesus
Christ to the intent that unto
principalities and powers in the
Heavenly places might be known by the
church the manifold works of God as the
gospel Works in US Angels
learn the gospel is unfolded to them
through
us so in a certain sense we can mislead
the Angels based on how we live our
lives there are unfallen worlds where
people have never
sinned God has to prove to them that
Satan was
wrong Colossians 1:20 tells us the blood
of Christ reconciles things on earth and
things in
heaven when God threw Satan out some
angels felt he was treated
unfairly and so they viewed God uh I'm
not sure he did right now they didn't
sin but they had questions about
God in the Zar of Ages ELO tells us it
was only when Satan did what he did to
Christ at Calvary that some angels
finally decided he's no good so for
thousands of years there were angels who
were still sympathetic to
Satan only when Calvary occurred did
they finally decide this guy is no good
can you imagine that sinless powerful
angels and so God has been trying for
thousands of years to handle the sin
problem in such a way that the entire
universe would be convinced we don't
want sin we want
righteousness when that happens and
Christ comes
we will never choose sin again because
we will show God now we choosing
righteousness not sin and so sin will
never rise again so our lives are to be
lived to clear God of false accusations
not to strengthen Satan's
accusation it's more than me the death
of Christ secured
Angels whatever keeps me from sin on
Earth will keep angels from sin in
heaven the Cross of Christ secured the
universe not just this little world you
can hardly see if you put it next to the
sun sin was a universal problem sin
didn't begin on the earth sin began in
heaven and so you have to understand God
raised up a special people to assist him
in showing the universe that is law can
be kept what is that group The Seventh
Day Adventist Church and you run around
trying to be a
Pentecostal what's wrong with
you you run around trying to be a
Catholic or Baptist or
Satanist you've been chosen by God to
assist him in convincing unfallen worlds
and angels that he has always been
right and Satan wrong always be
conscious of that when you make choices
the reputation of God is in your hand
and so Paul writes in Romans 2:24 the
name of God is blasphemed among the
Gentiles through you the
church you see the unbeliever cannot
give God a bad name he doesn't claim to
know God it is the believer that says
one thing and does something else and
gives God a bad name so Paul says the
God has a bad name because of the
believer
and every time God gets a bad name in
the act that gives him a bad name Satan
gets a
vote my life must vote for God not
Satan thank you very much for giving me
one of the loveliest weeks in all of my
preaching life you've really been
sweet and I pray that God will keep you
Faithful I mean that stay
faithful fix disagreements among
yourselves fix them you will be
happy God cannot releases power in a
divided environment he cannot do it
can't do it when we are one Accord you
know Acts chapter 2 verse1 and when the
day of Pentecost was fully come they
were all with one Accord in one place
and the Spirit came yearn for the spirit
yes my
brother go ahead I'm
listening what was the question
oh go ahead listen to say the
question
yes who will be involved with a time of
trouble uh-huh
there are two times of trouble there are
two there's a little time of trouble and
then there's a big time of trouble the
little time of trouble occurs before
probation closes when the Sunday law is
passed and we have serious decisions to
make will I keep the Sabbath and
possibly lose my life or will I be
faithful or I will join the world and
choose a false Sabbath that's the small
time of trouble when prob
closes there's another time of trouble
that comes upon us now that's when the
plagues Begin to Fall that's when
attacks will be made on God's people and
God will defend them during the little
time of trouble some of us may lose our
lives but once probation closes there's
no need to lose a life anymore are you
following me so there too the world will
not support the church the world is
under the control of Satan Satan
controls the Beast the Beast controls
the government and speaking it very
broadly so there's no one in the world
who will be supporting those of us who
are running into the hills no they will
try to destroy us because they will say
our faithfulness to Bible Sabbath is
causing all the problems so let's wipe
out this little group causing problems
for the whole world the world will not
assist so there are two times of trouble
the little and the
big if you get through the
little then there won't be loss of life
once probation closes there is no point
but they may be loss of life before
probation closes that's why I've told
you several times this week be willing
to give your life for
God you just decide yes I will it's just
a decision you don't go looking for
death but if it comes to the point where
you die for God you say
yes M but the time of trouble is coming
and ELO says it will be worse than we
imagine it'll be she said you cannot
imagine the condition that will prevail
on the earth and if you don't have a
relationship with God now you will not
make it
then but she said something that appeals
to me very strongly in the time of
trouble some of us will be taken to
court and asked to defend our
teachings while we're defending the
teachers some listening will take a
stand for God and I have asked God for
years I want to be one of them that is
arrested not for causing trouble
arrested for obeying God so I can go to
court and stand up and defend the
Sabbath and the second coming and the
law of God I've asked God for years I
want to be one whether he lets me do it
or not I don't know but I've told him I
want to be one I want to see the
Fulfillment of that prophecy stand
before a judge and a jury and defend the
Sabbath and by observing people have the
spirit tell me she has taken her stand
he has and then I said father now you
can kill me you've allowed me to see I
want to see see that with my own eyes
mhm whether he let me I don't know but I
kept I've been asking God for years I
want that privilege of seeing that
experience with my own eyes all right
God bless you oh okay well I'm not the
boss uh let me go where's the pastor oh
Pastor there you we have some hands
sprouting like weeds you make the final
decision
want
all right are we getting a
microphone here we are right up here
God's child right
here before we get that question let's
pray again our loving father in Heaven a
new series of questions is coming give
me wisdom to reply in a way that pleases
you in Jesus name I pray amen yes sister
my question is
this if at all we are the leodan church
based on what's documented Revelation
right why does God trust us so much to
finish the work okay if we are the
leodan church why does God trust us to
finish the work leodan is a general term
applied to a phase a period in the
history of the church it does not mean
mean every single person is leodan we
are living in the leodan period but God
will find faithful people in that period
to do his work yes everyone is not
leodan but generally that's how the
church is classified lazy and whatever
else leodan but there are individuals
that God will raise up to do his work
yes
hey Pastor ski uh earlier you you
alluded to uh the camp meetings this
summer and a lot of the Pentecostalism
the false speaking in tongues what is
our role as you know Adventists that are
concerned I know that there's some
Ministries online that are that like to
call out people by name by and I I feel
like you know criticism is a
characteristic of the devil be what do
we do to kind of help hold the line but
without crossing the line where we're
criticizing people
um the way the devil does you know
accusing us like how do we how do we
stand in these days for the
truth well to stand for the truth the
first thing you do is live the truth
that's number one you live the truth now
if the behavior is happening in your
conference surely there is a line you
can follow or a level of steps to go
through to have it looked at or dealt
with I do not propose openly criticizing
people unless it's absolutely necessary
because people can change so if you
think let's say your church is doing
something crazy then you can talk to the
pastor if you think the conference is
doing something crazy then you can talk
to an executive secretary or through the
pastor so there are ways to go about
addressing problems but I do not
recommend openly criticizing people
unnecessarily I don't recommend that at
all I've seen some things online I shook
my head and I just prayed sometimes all
you can do is pray I have this policy I
apply to myself I don't criticize
leaders for whom I do not pray that's my
policy are you following me if I don't
pray for you I don't criticize you I let
someone else do it we must pray for
leaders because the devil knows if you
smite the shepherd what happens you
scatter the Sheep so he works very very
hard on
leaders and they're topple then the rest
is piece of cake and so you pray you go
through the right channels try to
address the problem make sure it is a
problem and make sure it is is not just
you disagreeing with something you
personally don't like you must be able
to say this is contrary to God's word or
the counsel of Ellen White but the
church will get worse and
worse the church will become more and
more like the world
[Music]
mhm in 1st Samuel chapter 8 the
Israelites told Samuel we want to be
like other nations we want to King
Samuel said why they said we want to be
like other nations directly and God said
they're not opposing you they're
opposing me let them have what they want
and the church will do that generally I
say generally but there will always be a
Remnant that stands fast for
God next
question oh no more oh
yes hello Pastor I just want to ask what
is your take about abortion uhhuh the
church is against abortion is taken of
Life simple as that now
there's there's another statement on
abortion you can read in a case where
the mother's life is in imminent
danger or the child may be born with
some catastrophic uh
dysfunction the church allows it about
for rape and incest they don't include
rape and incest as far as I've read
mhm we have to get out of this
world we really do
we have to get out of this
world yes sister thank you um so my
question has to do with rebaptism
rebaptism yes and sort of like the role
that it
plays as a baptized 7 Adventist
Christian say that again I said as a
baptized 7 Adventist Christian you know
we go to these Evangelistic series and
we have a Reawakening recommit ourselves
to Christ and what what would be the use
what stage do you think that someone
should be re-baptized is there a need
for rebaptism just to recommit okay okay
that's highly personal but Ellen White
writes in evangelism page 375 when a
soul is truly reconverted let that Soul
be rebaptised reconversion must take
place in the churches I've told the
story many many times I'll tell it again
I was running a brief weekend Revival at
the church somewhere won't mention the
country I made a call 50 people came for
rebap
ISM so I met with him in a room and a
retired Minister joined me and he told
us in his ministry he came to the point
where he realized he wasn't growing
spiritually at all and so he went to the
conference president and said I'd like
to be re-baptized the president said no
the church would think you did something
he said I've done nothing but I have not
grown in years I need to start all over
with God and be re-baptized the
president said we baptize you at night
he said no no no no no no no baptize me
right in front of my church because
there are members of my church who need
to do the same thing and he was
re-baptized he felt he needed to start
with God again I was at a certain Church
doing a a a weekend a week Revival like
this and the uh the pastor's wife and
son got re-baptized
I went to another church did a Revival
the associate pastor got re-baptized
rebaptism is personal the fact that
you've been a church member for years
does does not mean you've been a child
of God your life may be like this
actually your life cannot be like this
it's either this or that it cannot be
this and if it's not that it's this now
it may be gradually like this you can
hardly tell years have to pass and you
realize wait a minute how did I get down
here it happens slowly if the spirit
convicts you make the decision in Acts
chapter 19 Paul came across 12 disciples
who had not been never heard of the Holy
Ghost he taught them the Holy Ghost and
other things they all 12 were
re-baptized acts 19:5 rebaptism is in
the Bible now you don't get re-baptized
every time you you know you come to
church late now that's not what I'm
saying I'm not saying that but there is
a place for the Bible never says get
baptized
once by the way if you have a child who
really wants to be baptized don't say no
that desire may leave the
child baptize the the child can be
re-baptized later on are you following
me there is no Bible verse that says
baptism can only occur once I am not
preaching several
baptisms I'm simply saying a rebaptism
is perfectly biblical and elwi supports
it never discourage a child from baptism
tell the child good we'll get you ready
and remind the child we're getting you
ready don't say
no there's a cute little story I was
preaching in Uganda years ago and a
little boy came to me about 5 years old
he had an open soore on his foot he said
best look look so I prayed for him two
days later the thing was gone so he went
to his mother Mommy I want to be
baptized the mommy said baptized why he
said I'm
Healed I'm Healed I should be baptized
so the mother came to me and the little
boy wanted to be baptized we didn't
baptize him but he had a good argument
he said I'm
Healed so I should be
baptized any other
question oh right over
here are there are there other uh people
with the spirit of Prophecy aside from
LG white and church no k n o Cano no no
no no not in the 7day Adventist Church
other have Arisen making that claim and
the church shot them down
mhm no when there's another God will
inform the leadership of the church you
don't by the way don't run around saying
I have new
light are you following me Let the
church Le to see this new light so they
can no
don't I tell you wherever there's
something right something wrong pops up
enan white is the last best Messenger to
this church why would God raise up
another one when we spend no time with
El wi
writing there isn't another I don't see
why God would send another he might I
don't see why but God doesn't depend on
me he does what he wants all right who
has the last question yeah where is that
oh over here do you have a mic oh I'm so
sorry we'll come back to you yes my
brother um asking this question because
of what is happening in present time in
what things that are happening now uhhuh
the Bible has
been has been written in different
versions
yes apart from King James version mhm
and I know also that different
versions that carry different
punctuation marks yes yes change the
original meaning of the vers is and
chapters so what's the question what
advice are you giving and what is the
church doing about it these things that
you have been seeing here now if not
that the person putting those things on
the screen is taking them from king
version we would have been having
different interpretations there but
Bible said that no J no TT should be
taken away from the word of God because
it changes the meaning uhhuh all right
the church does not own any Bible
manuscript the church doesn't there's a
there's a Bible well it's not really a
Bible but we call it a Bible called the
clear word written by an Adventist
that's not a Bible translation it's just
a personal commentary but it's very
helpful the church does not own a
Bible the King James version for 300
years was and Still Remains the favorite
version in Christianity but there other
very reliable versions like The New
American Standard Version or the English
Standard version or even the new King
James version they're called um word for
word translations you see you try as
much as possible to translate the Greek
to the English on an equal basis there
are other versions that are thought
equivalents I transfer the thought from
Greek to English or Hebrew to
English I use several
versions when I'm studying now when I
memorize I use the King James because
it's so poetic and beautiful but I used
the now I uh I don't recommend one
version for study I mean that would be
very narrow W of thinking my favorite is
King James but I use others to see how
the text is translated because some text
in the Greek can take one or more
translations and both are correct in any
language you will come across that
that's why behind the study must be the
spirit of God directing your
mind now I'm going to say this but I
don't have a Bible to identify well I
don't think I do Satan's major weapon is
deception are you with
me he accomplishes that by twisting
God's
word with all these versions The Devil
must be
involved have you ever heard of the
Queen James
version have you heard of the King James
have you heard of the Queen James it's a
it's a version where all texts against
homosexual it have been
removed mhm now it's called the
Bible now how God is involved with that
I don't know but even so you can still
read that and be
blessed because the changes only occur
on verses that condemn
homosexuality there's a Bible for women
where you have she she she and not
he
mhm now a Bible that I want recommend
even though the king jams text is in it
is the scoffield Bible because it has
commentary that promote uh the Rapture
and
dispensationalism and since it's
attached to a Bible it seems to have
authority even though it's wrong so I
don't recommend that Bible at all but be
careful with the versions you
use because Satan must have his hand in
translations because his specialty is to
twisting there's a version uh in I think
it's Genesis 49 where Joseph worshiped
uh not Genesis 29 Hebrews 11 by faith
Jacob when he was a dying blessed both
the sons of Joseph and worship leaning
upon the top of his staff his walking
stick he leaned on it there's a version
that says by faith Jose Jacob when he
was dying bless both the sons of Joseph
and worship the top of his
staff H now the Catholics can use that
to say see the Bible says you can
worship
things there's a version that says the B
the King James says confess your faults
one to another there's a version that
says confess your
sins now the Catholics can say see the
Bible says confess your sins to the
priest you have to be careful the
version you no version is
perfect but there's no book more
reliable than the Bible of all ancient
documents none is more reliable
than the Bible because when all the
ancient manuscripts are assembled the
the Bible is 98% if not 99
accurate for what you need for salvation
to understand Jesus Christ and sin and
the essential of the Gospel the Bible is
absolutely
reliable but the versions I recommend my
personal the King
James The New American Standard Bible
the English Standard Version New King
James
I am not a fan of the NIV but it's very
popular and of course when you study the
Bible always read what Ela white has to
say there is a if you download El's
writings to your phone you have access
to all her comments on various parts of
the Bible you study Exodus chapter 20
you go what comments does she have and I
place her comments above the comments of
people with 10
phds because the comments are divine
inspiration
all right my handsome brother right
here one oh I'm so sorry I'm a false
prophet sorry let's get back here yes my
sister so my question is a followup to
the the previous ones that were about
music yes so the way that we know um
like quote unquote Holier music or music
that is appropriate in the church being
the organ actually like comes from a lot
of Catholic ideology that was in the
Medieval ages and was a lot of it was
was um whenever Protestants became um
whenever they separated from the
Catholic church and they started doing
their own kinds of music during the
Baroque Period which was a lot more uh
style and Glamour and more glory to God
it was demonized by a lot of the
Catholics there and likewise the same
thing happened whenever um a lot of uh
enslaved people that were from Africa
whenever they would worship they would
use a lot of um music that wasn't
considered holy right uh but in the
Bible the Bible makes mention of
trumpets it makes uh mention of uh uh
tambourines thank you a lot of symbols
like all different various um kinds of
music all instruments from each family
and so what I would like to know is why
do we always have this discussion on
what kind of music is appropriate in the
church just because of things that we as
man have restricted rules upon ourselves
the Bible has already answered that well
I'm not sure the Bible has answered it
we have to be very careful the kind of
music we play in the church I was uh in
a certain country having lunch and a
lady was present who used to be a
Pentecostal and she's now an Adventist
and during the discussion over lunch she
said she attended an Adventist Church
and she said when she attended she was
confused she said this is exactly what I
left now I've come and here it is in the
this is what I left now even though the
Bible mentions tambourine all sorts of
things the Bible does not command you to
use them they're not commands you see
this is not a command that is not a
command the church has a statement on
appropriate again all these questions
can be answered the church has a
statement on what is appropriate music
and it has to do with the the the lyrics
in the the words in the lyrics are they
theologically correct the music and the
effect it elicits from people there are
some Adventists who want to
dance in the
church have you ever heard of Praise
dancing have you ever seen
it I don't want you to waste your time
but you take a few minutes go on YouTube
and look up praise dancing and you have
to shake your head you said what's wrong
with
people read the statement go online 7day
Adventist position on music this long
paper will come up and all the standards
the church the the fundamental purpose
of music is to glorify God and to lift
people into his presence music in the
church should not remind you of the
club it should
not I have been in some Adventist
churches where my eardrums were damaged
well not damaged but I thought they
would be damaged and I had to get out of
there just
loud I've been to church where people
were dancing in the
front some girls were dancing with
leotards and kicking up their feet all
the way to
Jupiter mm in the front of the
church this is what I saw and I just sat
there and I it's just one time thing and
I okay there are things I've seen in
churches I just say father come quickly
but the church must have standards for
music there is worldly music and there's
Church
music but we're in an age in history
where we can't tell the difference
what's worldly fashion what's Church
fashion what's a worldly hairstyle
what's a prop for the church what's a
worldly this and we just can't tell
because everything in the world is fine
with the
church when you leave the world your
mind
changes your mind
changes the Lord gives you different
tastes whether it taste for this or that
I cannot say all I can say is this what
is appropriate for God's people must be
different from what we experience in the
world that's what I can say and the
spirit will get us to do that but the
church has a position on what's
appropriate music do you know music
affects your
cells let me ask you this do fights
break out at rap concerts all the
time fights have you ever heard of a
fight at a classical concert it has a
different effect on the
Mind different effect there are no
fights to the classical concert I'm not
praising it I'm simply saying there are
no fights people behave differently you
go to a rap concert and I've never been
and I'm not going people fighting and
shooting it has an effect on your moral
Behavior Studies have shown certain
kinds of music improve your study
yes as you listen to it as you study
improves your study and actually Mozart
is supposed to be the one who most
effectively his music benefits the mind
when you study not rap and Country and
grunge and rock and heavy metal and
light
metal we have to be careful the music
that is played in the church because
we're glorifying God not culture culture
cannot have as great an influence as
Christ
the culture of Heaven is different from
the culture of the earth I'm giving
broad principles we cannot say because
we're black we have to do
this I saw this at a church I couldn't
believe it it was culture day at this
church and this girl with a a top and a
grass skirt are you following me and she
is twerking in the front of the church
because that's the culture of of the
tribe she's
from and I I said
father and the church yeah because
they're probably from the same tribe
yeah I S
twerking in the front of the church in a
grass skirt this
is this is culture
day but don't you know sin is a
culture the most powerful form of
culture is
sin and we've got to stop it
then we can avoid other forms of
culture what drives you cannot be
culture it has to be Christ and thus
said the Lord and the power of the
spirit of God tell you don't do that
don't do that you know the culture I'd
like to see in the church a Bible study
culture amen I go to churches where
people argue we need this and we need
that and we need louder music I have yet
to see a church fighting for more Bible
study I've never seen it
always we need to dance and we need to
skip and hop and we need to have coffee
before they come into the church these
are arguments but I have never seen a
church arguing for more Bible
study
h ah we need more L writings
never I'm not judging anyone I'm simply
saying if it's the church it must be
different from the
world all right my brother thank you
Pastor okay two questions one is U one
might be personal to you and please uh
I'm sorry already for you on the spot
but uh my first question is you
mentioned it before that the church has
tried several times to vote on women
ordinations yes mhm uh and has turned it
down mhm but that we are seeing mhm an
increase in women ordination in the
northern American Division what should
be the attitude of local churches that
are not in agreement with that attitude
and we are here not agreement with what
with the ordination oh well you just
don't well you have to a local church
can
disagree you can advise your conference
you want the conference to be in line
with the general conference statements
that's the highest voice in the church
a local church can decide with the
church board we don't want a pastor who
supports women's ordin you can decide
that so when a conference says we need
to place a pastor we want one who does
not support what the church opposes so
there are decent biblical ways to let
the authorities know we don't support
this but we can't go around being
disrespectful and running off like a
rebel group doing whatever we want there
are ways to let your displeasure be
known if you if this church does not
believe in women's ordination you let
the conference know please don't send us
a pastor who believes in
that other churches can do it we don't
believe in him because the general
conference has voted against it and we
like to follow the church's
recommendations unless the
recommendation is an obvious
sin God bless you my second question
then how long has he taking you Pastor
to memorize oh this amount of you said
you didn't of scripture in your head
what does it
take you said you wouldn't put me on the
spot this is the last question yeah when
I was telling my lovely sisters earlier
when I was a boy we had something called
morning
watch young people had to learn a new
verse every
day on Sabbath afternoon in the young
people's service we all recited our
verses it was nothing spectacular that
was it's like a bird flying a crab
crawling just life nothing spectacular
we all did it it's no longer done in the
churches now the Habit stayed with me
and I think God impressed it on me but I
love to do it not just In a Pulpit but
I'm driving I'm in the gym I do it
everywhere I go I'm reciting something I
am walking to the hotel I'm reciting
something I'm waiting for my handsome
brother Isaac to come for me I'm
reciting something all the time just to
keep my mind occupy so when I need
it it's there El white says in uh
Ministry of healing page 491 paragraph 3
that which is first seems Difficult by
constant repetition grows
easy we call that practice makes perfect
try it please try it what's your
favorite
verse John 3:16 give me one a little
difficult more difficult than
that John 3:16 come
on a baby in the womb knows that do you
have another
one John 3:16 all right I'll come back
to you somebody else what's your
favorite verse oh sorry what's your
favorite verse come on you must have a
favorite
huh John
3:17 Matthew 7:7 what does that
say receive uhhuh
uh-huh all right God bless you good
verse okay anybody else what's your
favorite verse yes
who Psalms
131 what 121 what does that
say I will lift up my eyes unto the Hill
from when cometh my help my Help Cometh
From The Lord who made Heaven and Earth
you will not not suffer thy foot to be
moved he that keepeth thee will not
Slumber behold he that keepeth Israel
shall neither slumber nor sleep The Lord
Is Thy keeper The Lord Is Thy shade upon
thy right hand the sun shall not smite
thee by day nor the Moon by Night the
Lord shall preserve thee from all evil
he shall preserve thy Soul the Lord
shall preserve thy going out and thy
coming in from this time forth and even
forever more the Bible is the sweetest
book to learn now
all of you together recite the Ten
Commandments why are you laughing recite
the Ten
Commandments okay okay okay all right
okay let me make it easy for you this
side you have two seconds to answer
what's commandment three
sign up for rebaptism this
[Applause]
[Laughter]
side okay this side hold on hold on hold
on what's commandment
8 yes yeah took you too long took you
too
long
huh okay this side commandment
nine yes Thou shalt not do
what Thou shalt not bear false witness
cover is number 10 well let's see I'll
give you the hardest one commandment
[Applause]
four you flunked
Comm listen to me when I was a boy you
had to know it you're sevenly Adventist
we were raised up to elevate God's
law recite the fourth Commandment King
James version just the
fourth okay
pause only the women
[Applause]
I don't know what version you're using
but uh all right men why are you
laughing
men give me commandment
two don't look around give me
commandment to
men sh sh just the men just the men
recite commandment
two
mhm
uh-huh okay all right okay okay stop
embarrassing yourselves
okay one more test are we seven the ad
yes or no what message should we preach
ah recite Revelation 14
6-12 you sound like the Tower of Babel
come on come recite Revelation 14 okay
sh this row Revelations 14 6-12 this
row no sh this row this
R
uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh now I want to give you an a for
being Adventist but I have to give you a
c for Catholic because you you didn't
get it all right let me just say this
please take time and memorize some key
Bible passages let me tell you the ones
we had to learn Isaiah 8:20 what does
that say to the law to the testimony if
they speak not according to this word it
is because there's no light in them we
had to know John 141:3 let not your
heart be troubled you believe in God
believe also in me in my father's house
are many mansions if it were not so I
would have told you I go to prepare a
place for you and if I go and prepare a
place for you I will come again and
receive you unto myself that where I am
there you may be also God bless these
two little girls right over
here we had to know Revelation 12:17 and
the dragon was wroth with the woman and
went to make war with the remnant of a
seed which keep the Commandments of God
and have the testimony of Jesus Christ
we had to know Revelation 14:12 here is
the patience of the Saints here are they
that keep the Commandments of God and
the faith of Jesus we had to know
Revelation 22:14 blessed are they that
do his Commandments that they may have
right to the tree of life and may enter
into the gates into the city there's
several vers we just had to
know if you're an
Adventist the Bible is a sweet book
exciting
book it'll change you it'll prepare you
for God's
kingdom and so I urge you as your
brother in Christ set aside some I have
some friends who are
memorizing I knew young
lady I said why don't you memorize oh I
can't I can't I said don't say that
because you hear yourself say it are you
with me don't say anything negative you
hear yourself and it stays in your head
say I have not yet memorized it Ah
that's a different story she decided to
try and she memorized the book of um
Jonah small book four chapters she
memorized the whole book then she
memorized some chapters in John there's
another lady a grandmother I told her
why don't you memorize she started she
started she did the first 10 or 11
chapters of Proverbs now that's very
challenging because almost each verse in
proverb is a verse un itself it doesn't
tell the story so it's really
challenging I think she memorized
James there's a medical
student in across the sea somewhere I
told her why don't you
memorize she memorized the Book of
Judges there's a young man studying in
Germany he's from one African country
very sharp fellow I baptized him so why
don't you memorize he started memorizing
just like that and he would post it on
WhatsApp just like
that God gave you a
memory now I'm not a doctor but my
prescription to avoid
Alzheimer's is put the Bible in my head
and otherwise writings it has not been
evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration but that's what I use you
following me the Bible and El White here
to protect
this so when I'm 500 years old I want to
be able to recite this and that and that
and that that so I want you to make a
commitment to God and to you do you know
um neurologists tell us and people are
experts in the brain when you give the
brain a new challenge it produces new
Pathways or new cells or new something
the Jin the brain is re it goes through
regeneration new things begin to grow ah
come on let's forget your fingernails
for a while and work on your brain are
you following me work on your
brain try to memorize some scripture
you'll be surprised how your mind will
become sharper and be
determined don't give up the Holy Ghost
will help you who will
try oh oh how nice ah God bless you God
bless you I know you're just pulling my
leg but God bless you God I really me
that God bless you if you do you'll be a
blessing to
others thank you very much God bless you
how many of you well
no can I tell my wife you sent her love
well raise your hand okay okay okay I'll
tell her sweet Church sends all the love
to her pastor thank you
working with you was as easy as a hand
in a
glove God bless you the Elder where's my
head
Elder oh God bless you brother The
Prince and his lovely wife Stella who
picked me up God bless you where's
Isaac Isaac is my faithful driver
wherever Isaac is he is always on time
always Pleasant always ready when I'm
about to exit God bless that young man
who took me back and always asking me do
you need to go this place or that place
do you need whatever God bless him God
bless him and God bless all of
you but a special blessing on the little
children who are so sweet God bless you
thank you for this experience and if God
works it out I'll be happy to come again
God bless you
pastor Pastor don't go too far please
yeah if you can come let you come come
over here
too pastor this week has been
a very very
um uh special week for us individual and
I said